hey guys it's Justine and this is my
sister Jenna hello actual real legit
sister sometimes they like think there
were sorority sisters she is oh thank
you being too old for things I recently
did a video where I was cutting soap and
some of you guys loved if some of you
hated it some we were confused I also
was confused in the entire making of the
video but I thought I would bring my
sister along for the thought so I
couldn't be confused as well yes well
we're gonna be cutting soap today you
saw my last video didn't you you don't
watch my videos that's totally fine I'm
not even upset about it I was in the
same room when she was filming it I feel
like I don't have to watch it so
previously I used music fairly large
knives but I thought let's up it a
little bit let's get a bigger knife and
add another person I gotta go I got an
appointment
where's your appointment tell me show me
it's not on your act now let's cut so
okay so to be honest with you guys what
I learned in my first video is cutting
stuff with a smaller knife is actually a
lot easier but I thought we should
probably test this out the thing about
this is it's really good for hacking
down weeds and things like that outside
like you have to be really swinging this
is not something that is good for what
I'm gonna be doing okay so why am I here
because there's no space for me up there
oh hello I don't like it okay well then
let's start small let's cut just maybe
something tiny just to give you a taste
okay but you're wearing a blade where my
body goes hey yes sit down I have a
question why does this soap have um
that's an Easter Bunny what do you do
with this soap is it like a bath bomb or
do you like rub your body on it this one
matches me it's giving me a headache but
I'm no seriously what like well what do
you I do with this fancy soap
I think I don't know is this a bomb the
girl was very confused as to why I was
buying so much let's looks like a cookie
I thought I should be eating it hmm you
shouldn't cuz you here I'm gonna give
you a little knife because it's actually
a lot more fun to cut with a smaller one
what should i do should I do whatever
you want this is your soap cut
this looks like an Oreo cookie what is
this so you should probably know Lee so
maybe start on this slide so like see
this like you just come off see look you
want to do like nice little slices like
this sure sure
father are gonna hate mine that's a nice
cut and then just kind of scoot it out
of the way so they can really see and
you want to cut real thin slices let's
show all did you see that cut sure so so
it's the wrong hand I'm even dexterous
so I can switch here so let's switch I'm
making a mat here
see look there's as much nicer to cut
this is beautiful so what do you guys
think of dual soap cutting no it's limo
finger slicing it'll look like I hope we
don't find out are these gonna be in
slo-mo oh yeah
so Jenna what do you do for a living
well I was thinking the same thing when
I did the first video I thought about
like what led me to a point in my life
where I'm cutting soap on YouTube I'm
not to do science degrees want me to
filming you cutting said Jenna under
science agree Nick's shooting like
feature films and documentaries but
today my friends we're taking all of
that knowledge and we are throwing it
out the window throw it out the window
do what you want cut so tonight I think
we need to test out the machete we're
gonna give it a big cut with this one
but what I got it
you should probably back up I gotta go
beyond where should I go I think I'm
safe back here probably mmm turns up
whoa
I'm worst spot piggy hit it in the
middle now is the point where you think
Oh what led me to this point in my life
does it look good
what the heck is in here I don't know
but you just drop something I'm gonna
get down so please don't swing your [ __ ]
oh god this sakes this is disgusting I
hate everything about this smell what's
this oh here you cut that half just a
little chalky it's very very vibrant
like nothing this color should be
touching your skin unless it's a freakin
carrot so next up what do we have let's
just like jam it just wait straight up
give it a jab oh I thought you were
gonna like you're winding up like yeah
that's nice oh okay
this looks good oh he's like cranberry
muffin this smells good I'll give you
$10 to eat it $10 just like take a bite
I wouldn't have to take you to the
emergency room that won't even pay for
the how much this will cost me that's
your own fault
I'll do it that way too
no I don't know I'm just go into town
you're never gonna sound get both out on
the soap
just still don't understand
there's nothing sometimes generally you
just need to accept the fact that we're
kind of soap and this is the life that
we're listening onion I've never cut an
onion but onions are gross that looks
like I'm like a beet okay I think that's
enough oh look at this one this looks
like the gallbladder let's cut it I'm
still you're not even on the screen
well you're shoving me off all that hard
work so I'll be noticed this one feels
like makeup is this makeup oh it might
be I don't know hmm that's like a
bronzer oh look how nice this is my
palette this is the oh wow how do we get
that off of our bodies so guys that was
cutting soap part to machete and Jenna
style the machete does not work very
well I don't recommend it if you plan on
doing this it's also potentially
dangerous but what about us Barney oh
hey let's give her I'll dig in there
let's take it out oh oh it's like a
little pom-pom oh wow look at that this
is a last soap we have Jenna sure think
about the soap experience it's fun oh
this smells good looks like a lemon
okay this one smells like Pez mmm oh my
god oh my god London pest should we
learn anything or cut peasant yeah why
not this looks beautiful
um yeah it was fun would you do it again
why wouldn't I as long as you're buying
alright
oh well guys that was cutting so part 2
here on my channel
Thank You Jenna for cutting soap with me
thank you for having me I'm sure you're
so ecstatic what did you think of this
experience it was fun
I mean I definitely enjoyed like the
little slices it was like very nice and
smooth some of the smells weren't that
great but yeah I feel a little nauseous
to be honest with you
definitely have a headache yeah you guys
like this video hit like if you want to
subscribe you can click Subscribe and
you can go check out John's channel it's
me Johnny I'll put all the links in the
description and I will see you guys in
the next video don't know what that
video is so now what's it gonna be you
know sue my channel is a mix of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]